el movimiento al socialismo el partido
oficialista en bolivia arrasó en la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
regionales los azules ganaron 240
alcaldías de las 336 sin embargo estas
no están ubicadas en las principales
ciudades de los 9 departamentos del país
la votación se repetirá en cuatro de
ellos se trata de la paz chuquisaca
tarija y pando en la primera vuelta del
pasado 7 de marzo ninguno de los
candidatos alcanzó el 51 por ciento de
los votos o el 40 por ciento y una
ventaja de 10 puntos porcentuales
respecto al segundo aspirantes
requeridos para hacer proclamados como
ejecutivos regionales el más es el único
partido que tiene una amplia presencia
en las nueve regiones del país y en
general en todo el territorio nacional
en la primera vuelta obtuvo tres
gobernaciones pero ganar las cuatro
faltantes no será tarea fácil según
expertos en algunas zonas de bolivia
existe un sentimiento anti más y anti
evo morales- lo que explica que el
partido oficialista haya perdido en
plazas importantes como la alcaldía de
la paz el alto con el a copa disidente
el partido o cochabamba y santa cruz la
segunda vuelta de este domingo se vivirá
en medio de una atención política luego
de la detención de la ex presidenta
interina jeanine áñez acusada por los
presuntos delitos de terrorismo sedición
y conspiración en la causa denominada
golpe de estado ante esto la onu hizo un
llamado para que las elecciones se
realicen en paz respetando las medidas
establecidas durante la pandemia de kobe
19 desde el jueves imperan el silencio
electoral y otras medidas de control en
los cuatro departamentos en disputa